[Music]
Samuel Leeds is one of Britain's most
successful property entrepreneurs a
high-flying investor a best-selling
author and founder of a leading property
education company
Samuel is recognized as one of the
brightest young stars in British
business following his meteoric rise to
success by becoming a multi-millionaire
in his 20s
Samuel is in the elite echelons of UK
property investors over the next five
weeks 13 burning property entrepreneurs
will be battling it out to prove that
they are the ultimate property investor
the prize 20,000 pounds of Samuels cold
hard cash to kick-start one candidates
property journey this is the
[Music]
previously on the eviction you have to
find and secure a no-money-down property
deal I know that I've been in the losing
team twice maybe person here does that
do with regret you're a big dick
up until this point you've demonstrated
that you can sell that you can refurbish
houses and that you can secure no money
down deals which is fantastic so
congratulations you're in the
semi-finals you have previously been
working as a group where you can hide
behind each other and things are a
little bit easier today that changes all
I need to know who is worthy of winning
my twenty thousand pound cash prize so
this challenge is when you'll be putting
together your business plan and today
Russell and Alastair are going to be
overseeing you do that ready for when
I'm going to bring in two of the
country's top business analysts here
we're going to go over your business
plans with a fine-tooth comb and they'll
separate the good and the bad ready for
the boardroom where three of you will be
evicted so like never before seen in any
TV business show ever the candidates
will have to compile a business plan to
demonstrate to a group of successful
business people how they'd spend the
twenty thousand pounds if they were to
win the competition and hopefully we'll
get to watch them get absolutely ripped
apart so you know your business there is
not time limit for this until Monday
morning at 9:00 a.m.
however you cannot leave the castle
until your business plans have been
handed in reverse today tomorrow or the
day after before we get started with
this we want to take you through the
basic steps of what we were expecting
from you if your business plan I want to
make sure the business plans look as
good as possible and I don't want to see
you guys getting ripped to shreds I do
so sit back and relax as Russell and
Alastair talk us through how to create a
business plan in the last episode
Hannah's team secured over a million
pounds worth of property with no money
down in this episode we get to watch a
Brummie and a Scotsman dribble on about
business he words and stuff probably
picked a bit too soon didn't we next
to be realistic if you're over
optimistic they'll see it and then they
won't trust you people have a tendency
when they're trying to sell something to
always do it Russell just said they
always go very very high on the figures
be super conservative when I packaged it
up deal upsell to an investor I always
go super conservative on rental income
ie I also it's lower than Isis and
refurb I always say it's higher than it
is I think by putting this at the top
Russell is insinuating that being
professional is the most important point
in all of this in which case I'm pretty
much guaranteed to be out of a job
aren't I do you know what we're looking
for we're looking for something's going
to stand out when we're not looking for
suddenly it's just read a book and said
oh I'm gonna buy HMO or I'm going to
want to set F Serbs accommodation we're
looking up something it's gonna take
property and do something unique with it
how you going to spend the 20,000 we
want a breakdown to the parent of how
you're going to spend that money don't
include any salaries and that because
you're not getting paid out of this this
is purely business investment a lot of a
lot of time I see people who do business
plans they how about the the go to our
under based on the asked for 80,000
pounds and 25 our that's for their
salary and they get laughed out the
boardrooms from this and then finally
big one
you know our SWOT analysis
do you all know how to do that today
wanna know what that means aunty so SWOT
analysis is strengths weaknesses
opportunities and threats say we're
learning strengths weaknesses
opportunities and threats next time your
mom bollocks you for watching YouTube's
hello mom
I'm learning overreact still that
doesn't explain why Russell right so
lopsided it's as if he's just walked off
the waltzers
so being honest - there but it makes it
at least know you're aware of it so I
would say this is is crucial and also
you're thinking outside the box if
things don't go to plan what could
possibly happen what are the threats
Katy the lady that John borrow two grand
from to secure his service accommodation
deal in the last episode is about to
receive a shock as he tells her that
he's sending her the money back good
good yeah thanks yeah everything's good
you know you sent the money across
yesterday I just want to say what
worried what we've been doing is it's
like a property challenge right and
obviously because you helped us by
sending it across we managed to win this
challenge
so we've done the deals do exist what I
was talking to you about but they're in
Darby city sends I've run through the
details with you but I'm not really into
service accommodation so we're going to
send you the money back but we also
wondered if you wanted the deals pretty
much destroyed that relationship now I
want you John team we're more than happy
to help you set it up and everything
we've discussed it yeah whenever you
feel comfortable it's not it's not it's
not Masergy I know it's obviously a bit
of a start of the blue isn't it so it's
just obviously you've got the figures
you've got the I you know an idea of
what it is just have a think I'll send
you the money back right away so after
getting some marginally stellar advice
from Russell and Alastair the guy's a
task with writing their business plans
as if they were setting up their
property businesses for real don't worry
they actually spent 72 hours doing this
and showing you the whole lot would be
as uncomfortable and painful as the time
I had to go to hospital because I got a
Lego brick stuck on my bomb anyway let's
have a chat with the guys and see what
property businesses they're looking to
create I'm thinking of doing a option
where I want to get a property you
the 20k to add value to it and and
refinance in rent now I don't think
could be a lease option because the
whoever I needed the property empty and
the rent while the works going on it
doesn't matter about that rent because
I'll get a bigger return if I do a add
more value so I've got a feeling that he
is where she was hoping the [ __ ] I'm
already feeling it from the start this
conversation yeah let's have a listen
what you thinking is a commercial find
the commercial property to turn into
luxury apartments so we've got 20 grand
I've got with this specific challenge I
want to show that I can utilize
different strategies to raise the
finance to do the development with the
money that are raised so I want to
implement certain different things so
instead of just going straight to the
developments with 20 random raising it
off someone else I want to use creative
ways to raise it okay all right what are
you gonna use a 20 grand for and yeah
I'm confused as well okay so it's 20
grand these one is if you articulated
like this in the business plan you're
gonna get ripped so hold on let's just
get it right before we worry about how
you articulated it at the moment there's
no idea well that's what I'm trying to
say assume the person that you're going
to be the the business analyst let's
come here the they're not property
experts they're business analyst so they
are going to be looking at a business
plan as a business plan you're a lot of
what you're saying to me is you're
assuming my knowledge it's just jargon
so you're a bit of waffling better
jargon so let me tell you what I will
you got it
it sure would say oh I would actually do
for it I wouldn't do it so some business
I mean you can do a sourcing business
which obviously I would if I were you I
would set up a letting agency
that pretty much just in renter ents so
you'd find people that wanted to rent
their house out and you would you would
manage it for them and you would do them
as as renter ents I'll run that I'd run
as a business and then use and then in
your plan use the profits you'll make it
from that to invest in property because
you're more of a renter it for me that's
what you've done so when you're when
you're going for you have you done deal
sourcing you could do deal sourcing but
I would go one or the other this is a
but this is I mean we're giving you I
mean you could 20 grand isn't enough to
really do much if you're just using it
to invest yeah so you're gonna have to
be creative to make the most out that 20
grand okay I've got loads of ideas I
feel like I've got too many ideas and I
need to really sort of pick the stronger
points and but I'm thinking focusing it
on the the current business that I've
got systemising it rebranding it and
separating it into the different avenues
that were going down and just keep keep
growing it because we've grown so much
in the last six months so in the next
one to three years it's gonna be crazy
how much we can grow especially with the
20 grand we don't feel that we can scale
the SS until we've put money in to
systemize and Mitch other essays we've
got a fully up and running properly and
then we can move on to get more projects
on the girl yeah and again we've got
ideas for that so your two aspects
you're the renter essay and the deal
source you know one dude both yep
rebranding marketing advertising and
updating the systems kind of like just
having a really professional procedure
so you said mark how much on the
marketing the rebranding no I don't know
I've got a contact who I've arranged a
phone call with on Sunday to talk about
that so what do I do
I think I'm gonna need to do some
research on that because it's not
something that I'm familiar with
potential investors like yeah to sell
deals to some people that would be
interested in this kind of thing and get
in the near matte about what we do and
how it works because a lot of people
don't understand deal sauce in unless
they they're in the property world you
know a lot of people that we know and
speak to who have money who would be
interested in this kind of thing don't
get it so I want to be a step above with
the rebranding and making our image more
professional because I feel there's not
there's a there is a gap for a more
professional kind of company to make
sure that everything is properly like
setup and there's a system in place I'm
a little bit nervous about my business
plan because I think I'm a bit in my
head at the minute with it my initial
thoughts on the business plan are to go
with the strategy where I can use
utilize the money to create more money
so whether this be a model to look for
investors and actually go down the JV
route on some properties and then I
could look at things like buy
refurbishing finance or HMOs and try to
build a portfolio of houses using
investors where we both make money from
it good plan
he's actually just written that plan to
build a multi-million back property
portfolio what a great start
yeah all right how the heck you going to
take that take 20 grand to multi-million
pound then my business model for this is
to do it in stages so start off with
doing standard by to exit as a JV what
do you do this 20 grand so what I'm
going to do maybe use it to do marketing
for to build my brand so that I can so
you want 20,000 pounds to market
yourself not just to market no one's
gonna if I'm gonna get into a project
which might be a buy refurbishing
finance then I can because I've got
forms
was it with the Ambassador so that I'll
build trust with them and help me grow
quicker so if you get funds it if if if
this is momentum to me if this is a plan
thing is you need to make you it is a
business plan this isn't like I was
saying this stainless to some of some of
the others it's not about trying to come
up with the most clever strategy at
least you've simplified it a little bit
so your business is by refurbished
refinance so your plan is is to buy
properties pull your money out and just
keep doing it yeah yeah and then you'll
and then you'll start renting those out
and that's how you gonna make your cash
flow yeah all of the money into one
house because I could use that money to
basically buy one house yeah if I won
the twenty twenty thousand pounds my bit
what I would do what I would do with the
money
is I would give ten percent of it to
charity and then the rest of it will be
going into setting up a business on
sourcing so I'll be setting up a
sourcing company I'd obviously have to
get compliant with the sourcing company
right sorry folks
I've got interject here it's all very
drivel II and not very exciting is it
apologies to John and Hannah but let's
move on to the next segment of what some
of these get their business plugs ripped
apart and their character assassinated
shall we yeah the first of our business
mentor smell something fishy in the air
he's as fierce as a shark moves with the
tide will reel the candidates in cast
away any terrible ideas and nail any of
them that flounder his tentacles are
primed it's Rex mackerel I can't take
the mick out of our second business
analyst because he's built a huge
property Empire and it's worth a bloody
fortune by building children's
entertainment and soft play centres a
ridiculously shrewd property investor
with a clearly banging sailor
it's James Sinclair and last but not
least Alastair Cunningham hello hi John
Ricky Ricky nice to meet ya sir Ricky
I've got this plan here I've read it I
don't know anything about you I know
what the challenge is I know what the
eviction is samuels fill me in on that
I've done a lot of property stuff myself
friends of Samuels and I realized that
I'm gonna be waiting on where he's going
to be giving someone 20,000 pounds of
his hard-earned cash for a property
investment so I've read this I want you
to tell me now why you should be getting
that twenty thousand pounds
then I'll go for this back up what
you've said so the business plan I've
got is based on service accommodation
it's a service accommodation lettings
agency so between 200 and 300 pounds
depending on the property to manage it
and you're gonna fill it up and you're
gonna turn up get new tenants in leave
tenants out because serviced
accommodation yeah so you're gonna
basically run someone's hotel for them
for two to three hundred pounds a month
okay the reason I'd like any money out
well I debated doing percentages and
percentages but the reason I did it was
because I've just asked you how you're
gonna make any money out of them because
we're operating in three different areas
what I'm asking ya not the area I'm
asking how are you going to make a
decent amount of cash out of 200 ounces
and loads of work in doing this service
to accommodate yes now I just want to
know how you're gonna make money out of
that how many you're gonna it's a lot of
work for ta'rhonda pounds a month isn't
it my all will give you 20,000 pounds to
mow a thousand pounds a year when I know
you can make four thousand then get
twelve thousand I just think what is
wrong with this blow okay you heard the
brief create a business plan that you're
going to implement with the 20,000 pound
keep it short and simple
I count 38 pages that doesn't follow the
brief of keep it short and simple so I
saw yesterday that James broken shower
is going to change plans change the
no-fault evictions and that's going to
be the biggest shake-up for the private
rental sector for a generation
how is that going to impact your
business so I mean obviously that could
impact it into especially in terms of
having occupied properties I mean
personally for my plan is based on a
service accommodation unit to a certain
combination plan to use
a cash cow and to basically invest money
elsewhere so the idea is that I've got
five units in Cambridge that I'm due to
secure shortly
I intend to basically take both a
passive income out there and a savings
pot so the passive income will help me
live and the savings pot will accumulate
wealth together to carry out step two of
my plan which will be to refurbish my
house and pull out some money from my
own residence and then once I've done
that I'll continue to use the money as
savings for step three of my plan which
will be then to have a large pot of
money come the end of the three years to
invest in a buy to let portfolio so do
you work in property full-time now I do
but I've only literally done it for the
past six weeks what did you do before
that so I was qualified solicitor and so
and so I worked in mortgage
repossessions oh well five to ten houses
would be more than efficient and to
cover why need per month I probably only
need three to be honest to live off what
I need at the moment to be conservative
but thank you very much yes thanks James
appreciate thank you so far she gets
more money yeah I mean if you as a bank
manager you just smile you're a
qualified solicitor really ago when yeah
yeah and it was good I struggled to find
some faults in her she's qualified to
list that she's you know very
professional she's a suit you know some
numbers she knows what she wants her
future to look like in five years always
the sign of a successful person you know
I said what you want to do in five years
I want to have this amount of properties
in this area
in this golden triangle bang bang bang
bang bang and that just shows me someone
that really knows what they want to do
there's a reason she's doing this so
this is she's it's mine I think about it
the company she is today as a serviced
accommodation company but the company
she really wants to be that's gonna
allow her to do that is have a property
business that she owns with single notes
which is an easier life she knows what
she wants to do if she's gonna achieve
it small a light or a lot you return on
investment in year one for this business
young six percent six yes modest
can I as in as in here it's not in there
he's going to business plan I've got the
profit margins in there and but the
return investment you only six percent
the profit margin is gonna be 8% and it
goes to 79% in year two and then over
80% in year three so I've just spoke to
the other candidates and their return on
investments are like in three figures
does that not worry you are you
confident on your numbers I'm confident
on my numbers I don't guess it damages
right okay let's just go through where
you are where you want to be a hum read
through this so I just want you to tell
me exactly why you should take 20,000
pounds of Samuels Honda in cash okay for
your business 1,000 pounds can be spent
on their hotels and travel so I FAMAS
the networking with investors further
feel from home I'm gonna need to spend
some place some money on hotels and
things like that sort of I'm not exactly
Facebook Ads but you know things I don't
think I'll be using Facebook has to
start with bar would be later but things
like that so today basically generating
the leads necessary and the rows the
rest and think I think it's about 21
pounds 64 the sage accounting software
what I'll need for three months of use
you down the whole diesel I do know that
these seven pounds 20 per month we're
talking about that's some pounds yeah
I'm breaking down solid Oh christmas is
coming so I understand the 21 pounds a
month for sage
so looking at your financial projections
yes I don't understand them okay as
simple as that
in particular I don't understand why the
costs drop in year two and then jump up
in in year three yeah and and it's not
obvious to me what the financial
projections are based on okay yes yes so
what I've done with year one the reason
it drops in year two is because anyone
affected in the startup cost as well
that are ongoing so accountancy fee
stuff like that I've factored that into
year one as well as the immediate
start-up costs in you to they dip a
little cousin startup costs on in year
two and then they go up again in year
three because the more properties we
take every year the more it will cost us
as a company to use the channel
management system right so that's why
they kind of go up down up
but after year three though continuously
the outlines will be increasing every
every month because of the more
properties we take on okay yes there is
some marketing in there I'm not gonna
lie some brand strategy so much 3,000 on
brand strategy and marketing 3,000
pounds on brand strategy and marketing
what does that mean you'd have to ask my
marketing guy and I've spoke a lot about
and where we want to go if I took 3,000
pounds off of you yeah I just went you'd
have to speak to my person my brand guy
is that strong enough sure I see what
you're saying how hard it is to make
3,000 pounds yeah how to get 10,000
pounds to young but I believe in giving
money to the right people so you don't
have to do everything but if you know
who to to give the money to do the
specialist thing then they can give you
so do you know what you want the end
result to look like from that 3,000
pounds yes I'm listening I would like to
make sure that we are seen as very
friendly approachable reputable business
branding both me and my partner as the
people the face of the company and the
people to go to the people that they can
trust
if you
their hard-earned money - in order to
find deals for them so could you not
just do that yourself using Facebook
doing Facebook live videos of deals that
you've done putting content on LinkedIn
you can do that all for free some of it
definitely yeah and we have done some
content marketing ourselves however at
the moment we've only sold eight deals
and the money that we're selling them
for isn't as high as I think that we've
got the potential I think those deals
are great but if you are seen as an
expert in the industry for you aren't
seen as approachable trust time to get
the work yeah and you think that three
thousand pounds is going to make that
happen I think it's gonna show people
what I think you want to smash the sides
okay I think you've underestimated how
difficult it is to find investors yeah I
think you've underestimated how
difficult it is to get them investors to
know like and trust you a big thing
about property sourcing is people have
to know like and trust you yeah you you
wanted you've got this great idea of
starting up sourcing business which is
fantastic but you don't know the
fundamentals you don't know the basics
and that's worrying and I don't think at
this stage you need to be gonna follow
this until you've found found out and
understood what the compliances you're
essentially treating as in the state
agent you need to act accordingly so I'm
an investor I bought a property from Ben
nabhi or Deaton probably whoever you
call yourself today and the property
goes wrong what happens I'm an unhappy
investor now I've spent you I've given
you money you've not fulfilled your end
of the bargain
of what happens it would depend on what
has gone wrong and why it's gone wrong
but in most kinetic cases when we have
had some deals fall through for various
reasons we've just completely refunded
the
investor without any questions asked we
do we're not bothered about keeping the
money we want to keep the reputation and
the business and with the people that we
have refunded they have been coming back
to it and bought a different deal
instead okay how many deals have you
sold so far today eight successfully
through our company
if you scroll to the final page the
conclusion you'll see the actual figures
there that says thank you for killing my
business plan next one but Street
strengths or weaknesses
right ma han-shan video marketing video
marketing i have estimated 7,000 pounds
which was to want me true that 7,000
pounds but i want you to do it in 30
seconds okay so 150 pounds per video one
video every week for the year so you're
going to use Samuel 20,000 pounds to
start building your own portfolio that's
based on another kind of strategy in the
business do why don't you put what this
is what this is a problem at I think
your business pants unclear are you
doing you doing sourcing you building
your own probably investments but you
you're using 9,000 pound of our twenty
thousand pound to start three or four
lease option remains so the you're
actually using eleven thousand of our
money for this yeah so this business
plan is going to take eleven thousand
pound nine thousand pounds but that's
not the point the point being is we're
giving you 20 thousand pounds to start
this business plan yeah you're now
spending nine thousand a bit to do your
own little thing can you see the
conflict there sure and with two
thousand of that that there is towards
marketing and developing leads that we
can share so which will be for our deal
sourcing company and for our own
portfolio it's gonna be a separate
company though so hold on hold on what's
going to be a separate business the
lease option agreement yeah
so the miser in this business plan
because that's if that's a separate
company should have his own business
plan this is for your sourcing business
this is for Ben and Abby property
sourcing so in reality you only need
eleven thousand pound you don't need
nine thousand pounds and I think you're
actually very cheeky
taking this nine thousand pound and
using if your own good eleven thousand
pounds for the source and business and I
think that's all you need Bristol told
me that I didn't
enough just doing it for a sausage
company sir - I don't get and what I
should do next okay I don't get why you
don't put all of the money into your
sauce and business and making that
phenomenal and then use the cash that
that generates to fund your own property
portfolio yeah that's what I think
there's a fundamental flaw with this
property this this this business plan
what do you think the return on
investments going to be in the first
year Abby I love your optimism we'll
just have to wait and see thank you very
much right so your your product won
money in money out gives a fixed return
of 12% guaranteed again as I say it's
it's a guaranteed fixed return but
should the property not refinance out at
the value we would expect then the
investor would receive as much money as
they could get back in the first stage
and then the exit strategy is any money
left in the property they would continue
to receive 10% on that per annum but
they don't turn the property they don't
own the property so what are they
investing in there they're investing
their money to get a return so if they
so you're a finance house my perspective
of was that it's investing into property
and learning how so it's so I tell you
what I tell you I'm struggling with
Anthony is that is that if you buy a
property you you buy property and you
got an asset if you've make an
investment in a company or investing in
shares if you're doing a financial
vehicle then is that not financial under
the FCA furnished control authority and
and and therefore what investment
vehicle is it I don't I'm struggling to
understand because there's no ownership
of the property so I'm really struggling
with that right okay
can you help can you help me can you
clarify that is there anywhere in here
where I can see the breakdown of what
you use going to use Simon's money for
because so you which section because
there's 12 pages for financing it's 16
page 16
[Applause]
pen ink dry business plants covered for
who face the shop in the boardroom
so this is the semi-finals
so after this there'll only be two
people we've gone over your business
plans Rex and James have gone over your
business plans how do you guys think you
did hide it well I've never done a
business plan before so it's quite proud
of what I came up with and how I
presented myself okay and tonight I
think my business plan has got great
potential to produce the numbers it says
in there and I think it's a good overall
business and product do you think James
likes your business plan I don't think
James gave me an opportunity to present
it in the correct manner okay so you'll
be able to do that tonight maybe yes
okay how did you do John I think it went
okay
I do think that James highlighted
certain points which were quite useful I
would take on the future what was the
biggest what was the biggest point the
biggest point was the amount I was sort
of spending on education and sort of
learning how to sell and those kind of
things you want 20,000 pound of money to
spend a thousand pound on hotels it base
it would be a finite truck costs I don't
think I feel about you saying I want
20,000 pounds and a thousand of it I
want to spend on hotels how do you think
that makes me feel but it would be a
holiday as well
no no hotels as in hotels for staying
after go to networking events staying
over if I'm going trout over there
traveling round
further afield from where I hope my guy
Ricky what do you think James thought of
you I think he thought I could have used
the 20 grand to invest what do you think
he thought of user as a person as a
businessman as a businessman probably
your girl do you think he thought you
were bad what like think he thought I
was good I thought you were terrible oh
you're terrible
why do you think he thought you were
he's what he's worth 16 million what do
you think he thought you were a terrible
businessman I mean the only thing I can
think of is Oh sat there looking him
dead in the eye taking on what he was
saying and I was confident with my plan
right so you think he did great I think
my idea is a good idea
terrible okay Hannah Hadley did
I thought I thought I did okay I thought
I answered every question that he had I
think the questions that he did have I
gave him the answers that he wanted I
was caught I was quite pleased with with
my question what do you think James
thought of you in your plan I think he
thought my plan was quite risky he did
question why I didn't go straight into
bita let's and but I think I gave him a
reasonable explanation about the reason
why I did it
and cashflow I think your business plan
is good I think my business plan is good
I think you can be tweaked in certain
areas to be very better but I think the
actual foundation is good yeah I think
my business plans good I think it's
something that I have been wanting to do
for a while but not having the funds to
back it up and I think that yes there
are certain points that I'd take on from
the people that we've met today and
talked about it with majority of the
money you requested was for branding and
marketing how can you justify up and it
was 3000 out of 20 Sir Anthony wants to
spend 7,000 pounds on videos how can you
justify that Anthony you know when I
started my business do you think I spent
a penny on videos I'd be like ten
thousand followers on YouTube on my
phone have you even done a video I've
released I've put some different videos
of ul7 set of videos yeah on YouTube on
YouTube oh sorry - on YouTube so you put
two videos out on YouTube and and now
you want and you said 150 pound a pop
per video where did you get that quote
from so I spoke to a videographer and he
said that's where you just rang one up
and like Anthony if that was your money
you're twenty thousand pound would you
really spend 150 pound a week on getting
a video don't or would you just shoot it
on your phone I'd probably say to our
Moffatt of course so why do you think
because it's more money you can spend it
on a videographer that you just picked
up off off Google first person whose
boat - I wanted to use the money to
invest it no the truth is you don't know
what you invest the money in you don't
know any idea and in fact most of you
are just clutching at straws trying to
think of stuff what can I spend this 20
grand on well maybe I could throw a few
grand on infusion
soft 3,000 pound on infusions of it's
ridiculous
is that not ridiculous I can see where
you're coming from Heather or not you
can see where I'm coming from what we do
not use MailChimp which is free why do
you want to use Infusionsoft and you
just start now it's beyond my thing is
if it was your money you wouldn't be
doing that if it was that your
hard-earned twenty thousand pound you
would be starting with whatever is free
so I don't think you'd be using your
phone you'd be using MailChimp did you
have a problem trying to a proportion
spend the twenty thousand pound was that
tricky what I didn't want to do was to
put the twenty thousand pound into 1 by
2 let property I think you'd have been
better to do that than say seven
thousand pound on videos in in hindsight
I see that that so the return I would
have got from one by two that property
would have meant that in nine Lots time
I would have been able to refinance it
potentially take that money back out
what I wanted to do was to grow my
business quicker and to buy more course
only boys betting seven grand over
twelve month period doing a weekly video
come on night what come on tonight I you
stupid you're not stupid you're
intelligent guy even you've been you've
had like four three four days to do this
business plan what were you thinking I
was thinking if I spent the money on
more expensive marketing tools I would
be able to works I'm afraid it's just
not how business works and I think
that's a schoolboy error Alastair what
what do you use for your sourcing
business which is the largest in the UK
I now use Infusionsoft but not until I
was at a point where my business could
sustain it when I started I was using
all clients I was using all clients
uphill but two months ago so two months
ago I started using Infusionsoft you
started a few months ago it's just it
just blows my mind and the crazy thing
is I was really looking forward to this
boardroom I was thinking I can't wait to
go over the business plans they're going
to be gray I really want to give someone
a break I really want to give someone
twenty thousand pound it deserves it but
now I'm just left looking at the
business plans thinking they're a bloody
disgrace
what's funny John I know he keeps
mocking nothing awesome just what do you
think John I just I do think that
perhaps I should put more thought yeah
yeah I think so you're a smart lad enjoy
what I am even here
to try and obviously grow our business
and grow my brand and nothing I keep
hearing this people want to build their
brand with some of those money but you
don't need expensive video equipment to
start growing your brand when I started
growing my brand I used an iPhone and I
used iMovie maker which is free
I used to Facebook organic I put content
out there I've loved what I was doing
that's how I got to where I'm at I
didn't blow someone piss someone's money
at the wall spending expensive extortion
and that's on Infusionsoft and and video
with us it's just insane and Ricky you
were all over the place James was
appalled at your business plan where's
your money gonna go my money we get
after today's conversation I'll rethink
about the money
where's he gonna go there it's gonna go
in on Infusionsoft all right I'll go for
you don't even know I'm saying I've got
a check for 20,000 pounds you've got
this idea do you need the money to do
that to do that business so generate
more cash flow you know do you need the
money to set that business up yes or not
yeah why do you need what do you need
the money for firm spin speed of growth
flight yeah what are you gonna spend the
money on 20,000 pound in your pocket
tomorrow what are you gonna spend it on
I mean there will be marketing involved
because we have to reach clients okay so
how much of it you can spend on
marketing maybe a few thousand pounds
maybe a few thousand pound a little bit
of marketing its 20,000 pound so okay
3,000 pound of marketing they want you
to do the 17,000 pounds of course the
online starting cost throughout the year
like a professional accountant that
knows about the property property on
industry but the thing is with an
accountant you pay an accountant once
you've made money and then you pay them
to do your books at the end of the year
the channel managers get any pain as
well is that the month you think yep now
you said you need money to start the
business and you're given the ongoing
costs like accountancy costs the the
channel managers you have a full of BS
mate you don't need the 20,000 pounds of
stock to start the business what are you
gonna do start the business anyway and
then use the twenty thousand pound to go
to Barbados for a few
Thank You plan know what's you plan then
or do you not have a plan
Frannie I love you an idiot or you're a
liar which one is it not any of them
okay I'm going to be a mine of you there
you know I'm glad you're not an idiot
well help me out me I do like you told
me that you need 20,000 pound to start
the business and then one say okay well
what for
yeah we've got a clue okay I feel like
my business plan with like money aside
for the minute the business plan there's
a gap in the market for this business
okay so what are you gonna spend the
twenty thousand pounds on bike on give
me exact figures now God know when
you've out three four days to work that
out
can you see why I'm struggling here I
can't sleep you're evicted off you go I
feel like it's a wrong decision okay
well you had your opportunity so off you
go John what are you gonna do the twenty
thousand pounds to my aim was to set up
a sourcing company mm-hm what do you set
up a sourcing company - well I would set
up a company what well with source
properties for I know what it means
I'm asking where the money would go so
the money would go in into lead
generation it will go into the lead
generation Oh obviously you can do a lot
of things for free and I can go around
to estate agents like a new view austere
parts I set my thoughts and coming up
with mm hmm one of the biggest sourcing
companies in the UK yeah we're gonna do
with your twenty thousand pounds I was
you're gonna use with the lead
generation money so now do like a
mailing campaign of directive and
doesn't need money to do a mailing
campaign you need to you need to work
you need to collect business cards you
need to put them on a free CRM system
like MailChimp I meant like sending a
direct to vendor letters and sauces you
guys between those abounds not not all
hubs
oh I spend on letters on letters it was
meant to be 1500 in doing force out of
the money gonna go towards twenty
thousand pounds the bulk of the money
biggest percentage think was going to go
towards education and learn about sounds
like he does it does John can you see
one woman I haven't when I spoke to
James earlier he did put me in that kind
of direction that that perhaps I wasn't
a good idea we now what are you gonna do
as an initial investment I wouldn't
spend that I won't spend the ten
thousand pounds on the yeah who'd you
spend the majority of the twenty
thousand pounds on you need to give me a
good answer in order to get through the
majority the majority where would be
spent on setting up the sourcing company
well it doesn't cost more than fifteen
hundred pound or so to do that joint you
don't got to clear what you'd spend it
on and to be honest I don't feel
comfortable giving my twenty thousand
pounds over to some today he wasn't
going to clue and when I asked what's
the bulk of the money gonna go towards
say something that's going to cost maybe
fifteen hundred pound doesn't really
fill me with confidence so I feel I feel
that they've tried to answer with things
that they think that we want to hear and
they we actually gave John three
thousand pound he probably would spend
it on a property John what would you
spend twenty thousand pounds on I would
spend now I would spend ten thousand on
setting up the source and company you're
evicted do you know the annoying thing
is if it was your personal money you
would all change your business plan you
would all change what you wouldn't do it
because when you start a business you
start a business with as little money as
possible not just willy-nilly blowing
twenty grand
only true you're gonna get throw there's
three of you sit here now can I say
something
yeah in terms of my plan I know that in
in a sense I'm putting quite a lot of my
eggs in one basket I would say is that
and also have a JV partner as well
potentially that's willing to go in on
this deal with me I'm front some of the
cash oh I think that you've took on
board over we spoke at the beginning
you've took on board the advice I think
you're gonna earn the money back pretty
quickly so even if it changes
he's pretty safe your plans better than
their two plans now I'm not saying that
you're necessarily the kind of CHOP done
some great things
yep fantastic he does make some great
leadership skills yes you haven't really
shown maybe but with this business plan
yours is the strongest and all I want to
be investing my twenty thousand pounds
someone who has a strong business plan
well I know that money I'm an investor
although the twenty thousand pound is a
gift Oliver see I want to see a return
on that in sense of you doing really
well and I think that you will from your
business plan you've not changed your
business plan so I think I think you're
safe to the pharmacist thank you there's
20,000 pound in your life now I
understand you're not fighting for your
corner there's no passion in you do you
have you bought this I feel like I was
wrong I spent three days over this
weekend really motivated level-headed I
know that there's been Arizona business
plan yeah these three days yeah were you
writing to not work as a team and lock
yourself in your room you've been
level-headed but when you're working as
a team you've been shouting at people
you've been getting emotional for this
task I have been the strongest candidate
over the weekend because other people
have been complaining have been wanting
to give as much because he specifically
has been complaining saying that I
didn't want to do this anymore saying
that I didn't care about it anymore no I
said the task was difficult and I was
jogging throughout the business plan
which I was because I didn't say they
didn't carry dessert and I don't like
anyone that lies the reason why I should
get through over our being is because I
know my business plan will produce
results I know that I can purchase
properties but investing in this
strategy I know I can find investors
because I have done it I know I can
raise finance I know I difference then
why do you need 20
because I wanted to put the money into
building properties quicker to having an
asset rich portfolio because at the
minute I have two properties and I want
to grow that you can add one property
and I've got one which I've purchased as
the buyer if every finance property but
I have another property okay I know my
plan will work because this strategist
what would you like me to do to convince
you I'm not going to spoon-feed you but
I I'm not convinced based on what is
that white room
it just sounds quite messy I don't
really understand do you will disguise
the buyer refurbish you find that
strategy did you understand how I'm
gonna put my money into a property so
tell me why it wouldn't work how are you
gonna escalate that into a bigger
business simple if an investor invests
into one of my products I'll take that
money I'll buy a property I'll refurbish
the property of refinancing give them
their money back
I'll get another investor and do the
same thing again you can't count on
refinancing a property there so how so I
have an exit strategy if the property
doesn't refinance out the value I expect
it of then the investor gets an option
two options they can leave that money in
for three years and gain capital of lift
on the property or they can get a 10%
return on the remaining money and the
property until the money's paid back
it's a safe investment for an investor
because they're going to get a great
return when I do all the work and at the
end of it I end up with with a portfolio
of houses so my strategy is about
building the trust in terms of the
business that we already run and but
getting more deals more cash flow and
aiming at a very high income in which
the return on your investment your money
is four hundred eighty percent you're
already saw some deal successfully we've
sold eight yeah in ten weeks but we've
also had like ten deals fall through
okay but that's not gonna change
deals fall through I don't want one of
the biggest sources in the UK and I have
deals for through regular listen you've
got your system
you're compliant yes we don't have all
the systems that would light out but yes
yes what you see our own system setup
that works and does the job yeah you're
selling deals and sourcing deals already
that's why I wanted to put half the
money into the company and half into
lease options to build more cash flow to
recycle but lease options the whole
point of the lease option is that you
don't need money to buy a lease option
yeah but a lot of time telling me that
you wanna you need my money for you
don't need money for you don't need
money for these options you don't need
money for a deal sourcing company
because you've already got compliance
stuff I'm just struggling to really work
out exactly what you're gonna do I feel
that's the same for Anthony as well I
was at the same front announce he's
gonna invest it into a property which is
gonna pull money back out but in his
business plan all the money was going
onto things
stupid mistake and he's not gonna do
that anymore what are you gonna do
different
well I'm definitely gonna do several
things different based on what has been
told such as not spending as much on the
Brandon so why use when there's a
thousand bound on right now well my
original plan was to to go down we care
about right now I feel like lease
options would still be a strong the more
stable than rent to rent and you get the
option of obviously buying their lease
options cost at least fifteen hundred to
get up and running but then there's
always costs associated like a rent to
rent such as furniture or sprucing up
the property you sell a deal for two
grand and then use that to then pay for
your lease option and when there are
deals that were selling this that is out
on the income okay so and some of the
deals that we've sold have been sell so
that other people other investors of
founders so we split the profit okay so
we talked a little bit on the business
and gets networking events and be a bit
more thinking on Facebook maybe that's
what you need to know is it a case of
you tramping too many things because
I've always said this being master of
one as a jack-of-all-trades
so answer these strategies by be precise
one strategy is when you need more
20,000 pounds to be successful in
business I think you've got a successful
sourcing company you've got the skill to
do Lease Option agreements I don't think
you need my money for that reason you're
evicted Anthony you've changed your
business plan massively Hannah's a
strong candidate you better damn well
prove yourself that you can invest this
money well off you go here's what is
super super grateful for having an
opportunity to be here I've learned so
much from being here got so much done I
know what I've got to do when I get back
hit the ground running and again just
super grateful for having an opportunity
to show I've got make myself vulnerable
and just give it everything I have I
feel like gave my best shot I gave it
everything I had I got to the boardroom
after some of the meetings today we had
I wasn't feeling a hundred percent
confident
I think the bet the two best people have
gone through to be honest we're having
spoke to them about their business plans
that kind of thing I tried my hardest
and there's nothing I could have done
with it our business plans got
absolutely ripped apart and I do feel
like some of the advice we were given on
how to write our business plan wasn't
the best advice so I went along with
that and then I got pulled apart for why
I did it but never mind I answered all
the questions that they gave me I held
my own in there
and it was a goodness
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next time on the eviction two candidates
remain as we head into the final both
Hannah and Anthony are one step away
from a 20,000 pounds tax-free windfall
next time for the final of the affection
have been 20,000 pound transfer into
[Music]
[Music]
you